décidément les gaz à effet de serre sont
tenaces en moins de trente ans l'effet
réchaud fort de ces gaz s'est renforcé
de 43%
un autre rapport signale que la
situation ne s'améliore pas et que de
nouveaux records sont enregistrées le
grand coupable dit le secrétaire général
de l'organisation météorologique
mondiale
c'est le fameux co2 le dioxyde de
carbone qui représente 80% de cette
augmentation
les niveaux sont maintenant de plus de
400 sept parties par milliard ce qui
représente 147 % du niveau pré
industriel calculé en 1750
ensuite c'est le méthane généré entre
autres par l'élevage de bétail les
décharges et l'exploitation des
combustibles fossiles
le métal atmosphérique a atteint un
nouveau pic en 2010 8869 parties par
milliard soit 259 % de plus par rapport
à l'époque préindustrielle
enfin troisième cause du réchauffement
le protoxyde d'azoté produit à 40% par
l'activité humaine comme les engrais est
lui en hausse de 123% le champion de
cette pollution reste la chine
un triste record alimentée par la
délocalisation d'industrie lourde
d'europe et des etats-unis vers ce pays
pour les experts la préoccupation reste
mondiale il a thorough pour
l'orthographe les jambes autres
actuellement les économies du g20 cumul
78% des émissions mondiales et des pays
comme le canada les états unis et
l'afrique du sud
n'atteindront pas leurs objectifs de
réduction des gaz pour 2030 s'il ne
donne pas un sérieux coup de barre
d'ailleurs si l'humanité veut limiter la
hausse mondiale des températures à 2
degrés par rapport à l'époque
préindustrielle
elle doit faire baisser ses émissions
dès l'an prochain
malgré tout il y as place pour plus
d'optimisme qu'il ya dix ans grâce à la
mobilisation des peuples pote offre aux
chemises rouges qui tapent un bon jeu
mais dit il il faut absolument accélérer
la mise en oeuvre des plans mondiaux de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre dès
maintenant
ici frédéric arnould radio canada
montréal